[Music]
the nurse has a number of
responsibilities in the prevention and
control of communicable disease in order
to fulfill them she must have a basic
knowledge of the natural history of
disease she must understand infection
and contagion and their relationship to
man she must know the various types of
disease producing agents for instance
the animal and animal like organisms
such as the protozoa the Metazoa and the
arthropods the nurse must know that
plant-like agents including bacteria
fungi moles and yeasts can cause disease
as well as those without distinctive
plant or animal characteristics such as
the viruses and Rickettsia
while chemicals are not disease
producing agents they may cause injury
to body tissues and increase
susceptibility to infection not only
must the nurse know that agents can
cause disease she must also be familiar
with the methods by which disease is
produced whether by direct invasion of
tissue as in streptococcal infections or
through the liberation of toxin as in
diphtheria she must recognize the
various reservoirs of infection and the
vehicles and vectors of transmission for
example in a disease such as
encephalitis the nurse must know that
the organism is transmitted by a
mosquito vector from its bird reservoir
to a susceptible host either man or
animal she must understand that a
disease may be communicable during the
incubation period the acute phase or the
convalescent stage in some diseases a
carrier state may develop this state may
be convalescent as in polio
temporary as in asymptomatic infections
or permanent as in typhoid fever she
must also be familiar with the portals
of entry and exit of an infective agent
these include the skin and the mucous
membranes of the respiratory digestive
and genital urinary tracts if the nurses
to know the natural history of diseases
she must be aware of the factors
affecting the disease process in the
body one characteristics of the organism
to host resistance
and three environment significant
characteristics of the organism include
its virulence and resistance the number
of organisms entering the body and the
rapidity with which it multiplies host
resistance depends upon external body
defenses which include complicated
anatomical structures such as the skin
the eyes and the ears and the internal
body defenses the antibodies and other
materials found in the body fluids and
tissues other factors contributing to
individual host resistance are age sex
and racial heritage nutrition and
general health opportunity for exposure
to a specific organism through
association and the distance between the
portals of entry of an organism and the
tissue for which it has specific
affinity environment the third factor
affecting the disease process includes
the various influences in daily living
these may range from climate and
occupation to social and religious
customs in understanding the natural
history of disease it is important that
the nurse also know the preventive and
control factors affecting disease these
include measures directed against the
infective organisms procedures to
prevent the organism from gaining access
to other hosts steps taken to reduce
environmental hazards and methods of
improving host resistance let's consider
first the various measures directed
against the infective organisms one is
mechanical removal of the organisms by
either hand-washing filtration or other
means
another is sanitization the process of
render
article aesthetically clean and reducing
the number of organisms disinfection the
inactivation or destruction of certain
organisms by chemicals heat cold or
drying is still another measure directed
against the organism disinfection
however does not always kill or
inactivate spores viruses or all
vegetative forms the most satisfactory
measure for destroying all organisms in
or on an object is sterilization
exposure to steam under pressure in an
autoclave is a common method boiling
incineration or heating as in a dry oven
may also be used for this purpose but
the time required to attain sterility is
often damaging to some materials even
though these precautions are observed
some organisms do gain access to the
body in such instances the
administration of medically prescribed
drugs including antibiotics has proved
to be an effective preventive measure a
second preventive and control factor
affecting disease is the employment of
procedures to prevent organisms from
gaining access to others these
procedures include isolation of the
infected person and the practice of
aseptic or barrier techniques which can
prevent the transfer of organisms the
third factor of disease prevention and
control is the reduction of
environmental hazards the nurse
contributes by supporting education
legislation and corrective action
finally the fourth factor involves
improving host resistance while this is
largely an individual responsibility the
nurse promotes it by active health
supervision and by encouraging
sufficient rest and relief from tension
optimum nutrition personal cleanliness
limited exposure and immunization
against diseases for which there are
available immunizing agents
as a member of the health team the
nernst must apply her knowledge of the
natural history of disease when carrying
out her activities in the prevention and
control of communicable diseases her
activities include adequate surveillance
for early detection of disease safe care
of the sick to assure satisfactory
recovery enforcement of precautionary
measures to prevent the spread of
disease and initiation of prompt
epidemiologic investigation to find the
source of infection and other persons
who might be infected she may also be
expected to immunize a family and its
contacts give prophylactic and
therapeutic treatment under medical
direction and supervise the activities
of disease carriers at every opportunity
she continues the process of education
of the individual the family and
community groups she refers certain
problems to other members of the health
department or to other agencies and
reports her findings to the Health
Officer and the attending physician in
addition to general measures employed in
the prevention and control of
communicable diseases the nurse must
employ specific procedures for each type
of transmission where mode of
transmission is unknown or uncertain
professional judgments must be relied
upon to determine control where the mode
of transmission is known as that of the
respiratory diseases the nurse must try
to minimize spread by contact to reduce
spread by full mites and to encourage
immunization when practical she must
also try to reduce air contamination by
proper ventilation by safe disposal of
nose and throat secretions and by
limiting activities which distribute
organisms in the air
skin invasions and infections can be
diminished by avoiding close contact
with infected persons or their personal
articles by combating or avoiding pest
insects by wearing protective clothing
when exposed to insect infested areas by
avoiding careless handling of wild
animals or their tissues and by
consistently sterilizing syringes
needles and other equipment invasion of
the genital urinary mucosa is best
prevented by the practice of personal
cleanliness and the avoidance of
promiscuous sexual contact in those
diseases which spread from the
gastrointestinal tract specific measures
must be taken to break the chain of anal
oral transmission these include
preventing contamination of water food
and milk sterilizing materials possibly
contaminated by sick persons locating
and supervising carriers and promoting
personal cleanliness
these then are some of the
responsibilities of the nurse with her
knowledge of the many factors affecting
the disease process she is better able
to assume these responsibilities and
direct her activities toward the
prevention and control of communicable
disease
[Music]